Cái bây giờ, người mẹ hai thành chiến tại chủ sở bãng như sân số bài mút thành chống hành hội,
tổng nghĩ thư tôn lâm đã tham dự lấy xả mất, chăng tiên điện tự đàn cộng xảm viên em,
đại hội thử mấy bốn, chăng tiên được xây dự nằm công cấp thung tiên chính thống toàn diện
bây văn kiện nhân dự và có hoạt động của đại hội, khoa đó lăng toàn ra chỉ để hướng
phát triến hất, cùng cố nhìn tiên và đồng thuật xả hội.
Phát điều tại mùi lẽ, đồng chỉ lấy cút mấy, ui viên Trung Ngan, tổng miệng tập mắng nhân dân,
phó trường bàn tuyên giáo và dân bàn Trung ngon, chú tịch hội nhà báo Việt Nam khẳng đình.
Già mắt chẳng thung tiên điện tự đàn công xảm viện Nam lại hội mối bốn,
là sự kiện của ý nghĩa nặng Việt quan trọng không chỉ lối với công tắt tuyên chuyển của đàn.
Mặc quan mấy chứng cho quý tâm đổi mới, hiện lại hóa phương tức chuyển thông,
dưới sự chỉ đạo sách sau của các đồng chí lấy đạo đàn và nhận nước.
Chực tiếp là bán tuyên giáo và dân bàn Trung ngon, chẳng thung tiên được xây dân công phu,
với tinh thần khẩn chương nghiên tốt.
Báo đã mạnh giả ứng dụng nhiều thông nghệ hiện nay,
máo gồm chỉ thuật nhân tạo,
tạo nên một nền tàng chuyển thung số hiện nay,
đêm lại trải nghiệp quan dịch nhất trong mọi đối tượng,
chở thành câu nối dưới đàn với nhân dân.
Có phần nân cao nhận thức chính kịt, sự thúc đẩy tham gia của quan dân,
vào sự nghiệp xây dân và bảo vệ tục quốc.
Báo nhân dân cứ thông vận hành trang thung tiên vào đàn ăn toàn chính xác giật này,
sinh đáng là một trong những công trình trọng bừng đại hội đại biểu toàn của lần thứ mối bốn của đàn.
Hàng định vào nhân dân luôn là ngọn cơ chính trị tư tường của đàn trên mặt trận báo chiến nước nhà,
đồng chiến lấy khúc mình cho biết những ngằm qua,
báo đã không gần đổi mối nội dụng phương tức tương trình,
khoảng lãnh kịt thôi, sinh đồng, các trù trường chính xe k lớn của đàn và nhận nước.
Các sự kiện chính trị trọng đại của đất nước.
Tính đàn chắc chính luận và bản sắp của tử máo tiếp tục được hành định và năng cao
gắn với uống dụng công nghệ hiện này, đầy mạnh tương tác trên các nền tạng số.
Phát biểu trị đạo tại mối lẽ, tổ mối thư tối lâm nêu gió,
trang thung tiên điện từ đàn tục sản Việt Nam, đại hội mối bốn là một địa chỉ số,
là hạt tăng thung tiên chính thống của đại hội đại biểu toàn của lần thứ mối bốn của đàn,
một địa chỉ thung tiên nhanh chính xác tiên cầy thần thiệt,
báo đàn một nguồn một trần một tiến nói,
trang quan vô quá trình chuẩn bị tổ chức đại hội và trình khai nghị quét sau đại hội mối bốn.
Đại hội mối bốn của đàn là sự kẹt chính trị trọng đại,
định hình cầm dình, mục tiêu và những luật phá cho xe đoạn phát triển mối của đất nước.
Trong bối cảnh, trình thông đàn nền tạng, thông tin liều chuyển cực nhang,
ra chèo, ra xanh, mối thông tin chính thống đều có xá trị như một điểm tới lệ xá hội định rứng nhận thức và hành động.
Bây giờ, trang thông tin điện từ phải hoàn thành và nhận vụ ổclói,
cũng cấp thông tin đúng đủ kịp thời, định hưởng dư luật vàng luận cứ qua học và giữ liệu chính sát,
kết nối từng tác nạo đồng thuận sạch hội trong vòng ngoài nước.
Tổng miết thương nhấn mạnh, trang thông tin đàn công sản Việt Nam,
đại hội mối bốn phải là nơi cập nhật chương trình, nội dung, văn kẹt, kết quả đại hội.
Lạc kinh phát hành thông tin báo chiếc, tại liệu hỏi đáp, giữ liệu luar, anh và video chính thức.
Mà yêu cầu mang tính quyền tác là chính sát kịp thời dễ hiểu,
mối con số, chiếc sản thật ngữ được chuẩn hoá, bản tin ngắn gọn sọ rằng,
có nguồn dận và thời điểm công bố tại liệu sẽ tìm dễ cải sẽ chế chế sản,
trẳng nhận tối ư trên thiết bị gì đâu để ai cục tiếp cận được nhận nhất.
Tổng miết thương liệu luy, lối với cán bộ đàn biên, trang thông tin là sự tại điện tự trong những ngày đại hội.
Gồm lịch làm việc, quy chế thông tin tại liệu dùng chung, hướng dẫn tác nghiệp chuyển thông lội bộ,
liệu ý bọng mặt, lối với nhận dân đây là điểm đến tiên cải để tiếp cận thân kẹn theo dõi thảo luận chính sát.
Híu gió quyền lời nghĩa vụ và chắc nhận công dân trong thực thi nghĩa quét,
lối với kiểu bà vào bản mẹ khúc kế, đây là cửa sổ Việt Nam về một đất nước lối mới, kỳ cơn,
văn hoá, chuẩn động vội nhập, là đối tác tiên cải thình viên có chắc nhận của các nồng phúc kế.
Hẳng định việc hai chiếm trang thông tin định ở đàn công dân Việt Nam tại hội mối bốn là bất đi quan trọng,
để tổ chức một kế đại hội đoàn hết rất trụ, kỳ cơ, đột phá phát triển,
tổng vĩ thức tiên tưởng với sự vọng của quốc đồng vộ của cả hệ thống chính trị,
tinh thần chủ đồng, chuyên nhập của các cơ quan thông mêu xuất biệt, sự đồng hành của báo chiến trình thông,
và niệm tiên, sự uống hộ của đồng bảo ra trong khoảng ngoài nước.
Trang thông tin sẽ hoàn thành xuất sắc xứng mạnh,
là ngôn tiên chính thống là vụ ký sắc bán trên mặt trạng tư tưởng phán hoá,
là câu nối bên trạng giữa đại hội và nhân dân.
Trang thông tin sẽ tử đàn công sản Việt Nam đại hội mối bốn,
có địa chỉ tại HATT-TPS, Hà Chấm, Kec Cháo Cái Cháo,
đại hội đàn toàn quốc trấm vẻ nữa, với các chuyên mục hướng tới đại hội đàn toàn quốc lần thứ mối bốn,
những trạng đường vẻ phán của đàn, như là nhẹp ký đại hội mối bác của đàn,
nống các ý kiến vào sự thảo phán kịp đại hội mối bốn của đàn,
các bài viết phát biểu của tổng vĩ thư tồ lâm, các phán bàn quy định hướng giận của đàn
và thông tin đà phần biệt. Trong trang thông tin, áp dụng các tính năng hiện đại,
như công cuộc tình kiến thông mình tích hợp chỉ tựa nhân tạo trạng bóc,
cho phép người dụng đặt câu hỏi và nhận câu trở lời chính sắc,
chỉ xuất chực tiếp từ các tài liệu chính thống về đàn cộng sản Việt Nam,
các thứ liệu bán kiện của các kỳ đại hội bản nổ tương tác lĩnh đạo đàn,
qua các thời gie, sửa thiệu thông tin các đồng chỉ tổng vĩ thư,
các đồng chỉ được bầu vào bộ chính trị, bản vĩ thư,
qua các thông tin đàn cộng sản Việt Nam, các tính đại hội.